foreign
but these firefighters aren't packing
their hoses these days they're more
accustomed to a different threat this is
the snake wrangler a former police
officer now head of the reptile rapid
response team
today thereafter a poultry poaching
python digesting its meal at the scene
of the crime we've got to be fast he
says the Trap won't work it might get
away
the three meter long serpent tries to
escape but there's nowhere to hide
after a short struggle it's bundled into
a sack and taken away
back at the station they've got two
rooms full of these slithery home
Invaders
conditions are overcrowded
but at least they get fed
Emergency Services across Bangkok are
receiving 60 000 snake-related calls a
year
twice as many as five years ago the
reason why we found more snakes in
houses is because the aggressive
expansion of the city they don't have a
choice because their natural habitat
isn't there anymore
but there's one place in the Heart of
the City where they're welcome
they're coming out now with a king cobra
which is the largest venomous snake in
the world and by extension one of the
most dangerous
and this is one of the few places in the
world
where they milk them for their venom
this is the Red Cross Snake Farm a
regional hub for anti-venom production
they extract the poison as part of a
show to educate the public
although this sensor produces enough
anti-venom for most of Southeast Asia
there are some parts of the world where
supplies are desperately short
in South Africa
and in India
because they don't have the official
anti-venom producer
and the big pharmaceutical company they
stop producing because they lack of
profit
back at the station the snake wrangler
is practicing his skills affected over
19 years but his advice is
don't try this at home
Tony Chang Al Jazeera Bangkok